car crashes a leading cause of child
deaths u.s department of transportation
says an average of two kids under 13 are
killed nearly 400 hurt every day
while driving in cars candace charles is
live from university medical center's
healthy living institute how do to
protect the kids in those cars it looks
like you're in the back seat right there
in a car seat with the kids candice
that's right i am nate good morning to
you good morning folks you know this
just like that follows that is that 40
percent nearly 40 percent of the
children that do pass away and these car
crashes are par aren't properly
restrained so we want to make sure we
give you kind of a demonstration and i'm
joined by nurse joe she come back and
she is going to show us a little bit
about how to put in the rear-facing car
seat that's usually for our smallest
passengers correct yes this one here
the important thing to remember is that
there are so many different types of
vehicles and model seats so it's
important to read the manual to your car
as well as well as the seat so that's
going to dictate a little bit better on
where we're going to place the seat how
we're going to place the seat this
particular seat was installed using a
seat belt but the locking mechanism
itself is on the car seat itself when we
check to make sure that it's properly
installed we want to make sure that
there is no movement more than an inch
side to side
and you go ahead and do a little shake
for that right right so as you can see
there is no movement side to side or
back and forth the locking mechanism
itself actually is is within the car
seat itself so if we move this out of
the way so you can kind of see it here
right it's all kind of laid out for you
it's right right in here i mean that is
how we lock it so there is oh let's not
injure our baby here right we got to put
our baby back right now but i know you
guys will have an event coming up where
you'll be able to show folks how to do
this it is actually on saturday
september 4th which is 24 24th yes which
is the uh child safety passenger seat
day as well right it's national car seat
on national car seat check saturday it's
from 8 to 11 at sunrise acres all right
perfect and i heard you guys will
actually be giving out some car seats as
well yes we will be giving out car seats
to those that qualify and making sure
that our littlest passengers and even
our those are a little bit older are
there safe because that's our main goal
prevent injury and death and make sure
that they're nice and safe when they're
riding in a vehicle awesome thank you
there such a you're awesome we
appreciate your time here and we will
make sure to have a full demonstration
for you guys on the newsnow.com website
so check it out there for now live from
umc i'm candice charles 8 news now